from the belly of production there's a
hallway that leads into the studio I
liken it to the pathway that players
walk through to get out onto the field
that live element is never lost on us
you're hosting a show while working out
while engaging with thousands of people
when that producer counts me down
there's nothing but go
I grew up in a immigrant family my
mother is a refugee from Cuba my father
from Puerto Rico and they really created
themselves
my mother was an example of a superhero
for me she paved the way for me to say
yeah you can write your own story I
really am a walking example of how you
can reframe the direction of your life I
did not grow up an athlete I was arts
and crafts kid I was the kid who was
good at school and I didn't know why I
felt so compelled to physically just put
one foot in front of the other but I was
in law school and one day I was like
maybe I'll run home instead of driving
home
[Music]
for me that unlocked powers that I'd
never knew I had I realized that when
you step into your power it gives people
permission to do the same thing so if I
can be a small catalyst in that idem neo
try every single day on the bike peloton
instructors are required to put so much
energy into every ride into every
workout we actually have to Train like
professional athletes to teach the
instructor is not just a body on a bike
they are the conductor of an orchestra a
lot of people don't know that
instructors spend hours for every single
playlist for every 30 or 45 minutes of
music and injector has been hours
curating that journey there is an
element to what we produce that is truly
a show there's lighting there's music
there's levels our production department
rivals any network we produce 14 hours
of live programming every day from our
studio in New York City and we broadcast
to thousands of bikes across the country
other members can see and high-five each
other and see themselves on the leader
board and keeps them coming back we're
doing something that's never been done
before and people are responding to it I
received a message from a mother who
said thank you so much for your
20-minute ride because I can feel like a
badass during nap time like I really am
stronger than I thought I was I was like
mic drop bike Wayne do you know how
amazing it is what you just did I really
truly approach every ride hoping that it
plants a seed of strength in someone's
life I want people to leave my class
feeling like they stepped into their
power